قواعد صار ما تحكمها هؤلاء المتسابقين
اشخاص من الجنسين ومن جميع الاعمار
يستجمعون كامل قواهم لاعطاء اكبر قدر من
الدفع والوصول بمقذوفاتهم الى ابعد مسافه
ممكنه قذائف لا تشكل خطرا او تهديدا على
الاخرين فهي ليست الا بيضا مسلوقا منذ
سنوات ينظم سكان قريه
في يوم احد عيد الفصح مسابقه رمي البيض
التقليديه التي تجذب كل عام عده مئات من
المشاركين المتحمسين تقليد قديم ابتدعوه
منذ زمن لكنه تطور حتى اصبح مسابقه تجذب
الكبار قبل الصغار فالمدينه الواقعه بين
فرانكفورت تفخر باستضافه المسابقه السنويه
لبيض حقيقي مصبوغ بالالوان
المسابقه لا تتم الا وفق قواعد صارمه
اهمها ان كل مشاركين لديه كميه محدده من
البيض لكن اذا انكسرت اي بيضه مسلوقه يخرج
المتسابق من المنافسه على الفور وهناك
طريقه معينه للامساك بالبيضه لا يجيدها
الا المهاره في تلك المسابقه
[موسيقى]
التحدي الاصعب هو ما بعد رمي البيضه بشكل
صحيح فمن الضروري جدا ان تهبط البيضه
سليمه دون اي خدش او كسر قاطعه عشرات
الامتار حسب كل قوه رامي بيض فالرقم
القياسي الحالي لم يكسر منذ عام 2002 اذ
يبلغ 78 مترا
ك
هذه المسابقه لها اهميتها الخاصه عند سكان
المنطقه فهي تمثل فرصه كبيره لالتقاء سكان
البلده واجتماعهم مع بعضهم كما ان هناك
سائحين يحرصون على زياره هذه الفعاليات
ومشاهدتها خاصه ان هذه هي النسخه الرابعه
والثلاثون لمسابقه رمي البيض
[موسيقى]